a few months ago facebook changed their
name to meta why because they're gonna
make a bet the company style investment
in the metaverse they believe that this
is where the whole world is going so
we're gonna live in these digital worlds
facebook created one called horizon
worlds and in that they're going to
allow their users to actually buy and
sell virtual goods now this sounds like
a pretty cool idea and maybe it works
maybe it doesn't i'm not really sure but
one thing i do know is that facebook
simultaneous to their investment in the
metaverse has been under a ton of
competitive pressure there's been this
epic battle fighting out between
facebook and apple as one example apple
continues to introduce all sorts of
privacy features that make it harder for
facebook to actually conduct their
advertising business inside of the
facebook ecosystem at the same exact
time that that's happening facebook
continues to yell and scream about
apple's 30 transaction fee in the apple
app store and so now all of a sudden
after facebook has promised that their
transaction fees will be lower than
apple's and their promise to creators
that they'll help them make more money
we're starting to get a look at some of
the math and what we see is inside of
the quest store facebook's planning a 30
transaction fee matching exactly what
apple does but on top of that if
somebody's to sell a virtual good inside
of the horizon world's metaverse there
could be up to a 25
charge on top of the 30 one which means
that actually facebook in some cases
could be taking up to 50 percent of
transactions according to the new york
post this stuff is still up for debate
and maybe facebook will change it maybe
they won't but if you change your name
from facebook to meta and you're gonna
make a big bet my guess is that you're
actually gonna have to reduce the
transaction fees not increase them
because ultimately facebook is having a
crisis right now their entire business
is reliant on the users coming back and
they're also gonna have to convince a
brand new cohort of users to enter into
the metaverse they don't have any of
those users and neither does anybody
else but if the metaverse is gonna be a
thing and facebook believes they can be
at the forefront of it they're gonna
have to treat people much better a 50
transaction fee would be absolutely
insane i think that there is zero
percent chance that they'll be able to
do this in the steady state maybe it's
just the initial transaction fee and
they bring it down or maybe there's so
much pushback and negative feedback that
they change it before they ever even
launch all i know is that if you want to
build a metaverse you have to reduce the
friction for people to actually go ahead
and adopt this technology you can't
simply have high transaction fees make
them buy a headset also not have them be
familiar with the technology and just
think that magically they're going to be
metaverse users for me personally sure
there might be some use cases for the
metaverse but if our friends in town i
want to go meet them in person for
dinner but maybe i want to actually
train for a business or i want to
actually have some sort of experience
via this digital virtual world that's
all on the table but not with 50
transaction fees so let's pay attention
let's see what happens here but a 50
transaction fee is absurd i don't think
there's any way facebook will actually
roll this out and keep it at 50
or their entire business will be at risk
hey you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time